oh hi didn't see their one good pro tip
for making a feature film it's probably
have as many meetings as you possibly
can before you film something even if
you have a script that you feel like is
super clear
somebody's gonna mess something up or
misinterpret it or you get to talk to
everybody talk to people as much as you
can
this just happened to my edit yeah yeah
I think our rage is crashed I'm sorry
guys
god damn it Peter we're gonna have to go
on the archery runs no get substitute
for target yeah sorry it's not fun let
me ride your one wheel Brendan
never going to touch a Minecraft roster
together at Cal in a little mouse but
I'm just just no more I used the one
wheel the more I realized how much I
loved it
but here's the thing with the one wheel
I've been borrowing it from the company
they didn't give it to us and borrowing
it but I don't want to give it back
can't ride my moose board in the office
some of the adventures with this thing
so many thoughts
hmmm is that
great thing I wanted to show you our
tree white riding this thing I did the
hololens and off our new smart tree but
no
ah Smith Singh why do you do that
a sort of tiny piece of the video keeps
changing 54 seconds to get to John Cena
we should try to hit him in 15 between
we keep going back and forth between
techno music or John Cena theme like
music each song has its own rhythm
introduces a new pace yeah
the people are invested in the story and
kind of gotten hooked into action see
that would hopefully pay off and feel
gives people that the shot isn't
necessarily the best action shot but
it's a good comedy shot now the crafting
stuff watching this more more stuff just
by so fast without setup that I feel
like you're missing out the whole the
whole Minecraft but I think I'm gonna
stay green stay with it you know boy
what is that whole sequence was you call
something out than John Cena use no I
also didn't have a good Johnson I
understand what the scenes I'm pointing
said watching it down is epithet is
watching out the crafting stuff book
blows by so fast that it feels like it
shouldn't even be there
and the whole point of it not even being
there then we lose the whole connection
to my account okay
I do actually agree honestly it's it's a
piece that has a couple challenges
facing it yeah we're wearing my car
costumes quick we're doing very very
there's very little minecraft stuff
other than that in the piece right now
they're a Minecraft or beaver
I mean people make things in Minecraft
all the time do stuff that's not even
related to what you're supposed to be
doing in Minecraft
there's no supposed to be doing anything
like that it's just a world so but
here's the thing we could have done was
wrestling it was like 20 times better if
we weren't wearing the costumes so why
did we choose put them on because
they're fun right but the thing is it's
very funky and they're bulky and they
look them they're there these wrestling
moves are just the moves trying and
trying to do them as best as we can at
the costumes not haha look how like the
characters themselves realize how hard
it is it's like us as an audience
realizes how hard it is because we see
the awkward movement but the characters
are like completely unaware of that it
wasn't shot or to set it wise to be
anything fact what we have right here it
see we add an edit here we have lots of
footage you can
pretty set about how much the video
would be so I'll let you guys I was
gonna give you that's it Peter obviously
being the one responsible for the raid
going on today I volunteered him to
shoot a pokeball off of his head
archery cell because I've been
practicing and I'm ready for this
tournament are you ready it is cool
you
oh yeah you can milk anything with
nipples I have nipples Greg could you
milk me